you said that you thought that you were
a bad talk show guest and I was watching
and I thought that's not true I think
you've been on my show and you've been
you've been great you've been terrific
well that's nice of you to say yeah not
really I did a whole episode of the show
actually about yeah you know how I'm not
I think I just think for me it's a
little bit of an uphill battle because
when people tune in to a talk show
they're like ooh what celebrity am I
gonna see and what are they going to
talk about and then they see me come out
and then they're like all right what is
this guy got you know what I mean so
it's like I have to like tell you know I
have to be it's the pressures on but I
and I had a really great talk show story
a great anecdote but I already told it
on two of your competitors shows Jimmy
Kimmel and Seth Meyers right right I've
heard those I've heard about those shows
yeah right and so your producer was like
you can't tell it a third time
yeah the I that you told it twice but to
try and tell it a third time is yeah
right mine criminal yeah so I was like
well I guess I have to just talk about
kind of my life like my regular life
today and I was a little nervous about
it so I actually decided to bring a
backup guest tonight I'm sorry I've been
doing this a long time I've never heard
of anyone bringing a backup guess I I
just think it would make you know it
would make me feel a bit better because
I don't know I was gonna go so that way
if it's if it's not working or my
story's not good you you have the
ability to switch over to another guest
I've never heard I've never heard these
shows have been around for like 70 years
I've never heard of anybody doing this
well it's it also helps me kind of feel
a little better too because it takes the
pressure off me a bit I mean hopefully
you want to use them but it just is okay
if I bring them out now I didn't know
it's a backup guest okay okay Susan do
you want to come out now or
[Applause]
[Music]
but how did you get susan sarandon to
come out here
I got her through my Booker I guess I
have a better Booker than you it's just
incredible is an actress named Susan
Susan has she's an oscar-winning actress
amazing career she's been doing stuff
for a decade she has so many great
stories about things from the industry
or her life that are really exciting
right so she's a great backup and if it
doesn't go well I think you know if it's
not going well you have that option but
I'm excited about what I'm talking about
tonight so you're saying that I should
talk to you I mean I'm just ready to get
swapped in she's going there as a backup
it's kind of like you know how planes
have like two engines yes oh yeah
so you just talk to me and you know you
ideally we're not gonna have to you okay
okay what do you want to talk about all
right so so I don't know if there's any
pet owners out there but I have two
adorable cats named rocket and Jackie
and for pet owners you know this but the
thing that's so exciting about having
pets is their unique personalities so
rocket is he's he's a red cat with blue
eyes and he's so sweet like they'll come
up to you at the door and just he'll be
right there and he's so beautiful I
always say you could be a model you
could be a pretty good model on like cat
food bags but Jackie on the other hand
she's she's a little bit of a more
unpredictable personality so she'll do
this thing where she'll lie on her belly
like she wants to Pat's on her belly or
on her back like she wants pets on her
belly and then when you pet her she'll
hiss and swipe at you so pretty uh
pretty good Susan do you have pets well
why are you why are you talking to her I
thought I'd just pull her into the
conversation and it's a big deal that
she's here so I thought right but she's
only here is the backup and you're only
supposed to talk to her if the story's
not going well but I thought it was
right no it was going pretty well okay
so I didn't I think you said yeah we
sometimes your cat swipes at you I mean
you can talk to her if you if you
thought that was no no no I'm sorry I
know you're listen please no let's share
more about your pets but some we want to
hear more about Nathan's pets
okay well I also have like other feeders
and they're they're litter set up on
automatic like a litter robot and so
it's like you can go away for the whole
day and the food comes out in the litter
cycles automatically automatically yeah
yeah and I also jackie is really funny
when she's uh she does this thing where
she guards the bedroom door and I know
you everyone's heard the expression a
guard dog yeah
but he's kind of a guard cat guard cat
yeah yeah I'm told you brought a clip
yeah I have a clip from the show is that
I'm yeah I think the show is that good
are you yes are we done with the banter
yeah that w did great on the banner that
your cats have very different
personalities the two of them okay great
well yeah anymore
banter thank you
[Applause]
you don't think of her a big thing she
didn't do anything I told the story
anyways yeah so this clip which I set it
up or yeah set it up alright so in the
store and the show I help struggling
businesses so in this one I helped a
computer repair shop and the biggest
problem when you go to a computer repair
shop is you're nervous that the repair
technicians are going to look at your
private photos or nude photos that you
have mm-hm
so I suggest that they have a fully
asexual repair staff to solve that
problem so yeah
let's think about this clip from Nathan
for you
[Music]
[Applause]
that's not the clap that's a great clip
yeah that's a clip that was amazing that
was the backup clip yeah
obviously it's Susan that was the backup
clip uh-huh well now I can't yeah well
how would you want to play a minor we
don't have time well they mess that's
the wrong yeah you just fine no there's
actually what's that there's one more
thing I just wanted to talk to you about
dad so she Susan's from New York and I
had to cover the cost of her flight to
come out here and she has to fly first
class it was kind of expensive and I
thought since she did appear on your
show do you want to go 50-50 on that
[Applause]
it's expensive yes Nathan for you and
hotel - I understand I understand have
fun all well yeah fifty-fifty on on
everything anyhoo I talked to after your
producer yeah talk to Andy and he'll
take care of you I got your buddy
yeah he has everything Nathan for you
there's Thursdays at 10:00 on Comedy
Central it is one of the funniest shows
on television it's got a special
two-hour finale on November 9th damn
you're funny Nathan fielder
[Applause]
you